[Music]
sixty-four million years in the making
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom Seas
released this year starring Chris Pratt
Bryce Dallas Howard and Jeff Goldblum
the film continues the long-running
dinosaur franchise that is based on the
book Jurassic Park
by Michael Crichton the movie deals with
heavy subjects such as extinction
genetic engineering and human cloning
this brings an element of sophistication
to the film that its predecessor lacked
and adds a wealth of discussion even if
the film overall is slightly mediocre
throughout this film I will be
discussing the movies ending the
post-credits scene that follows their
and what I believe the sequel will focus
on there will be heavy spoilers so I
highly recommend that you give this
video a Miss if you haven't watched the
film already without the way I'm
definition and this is my ending
explained video for Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom by the film's end Isla
Nublar has been completely destroyed due
to a volcanic eruption surviving
extinction once more several of the
dinosaur species have been rescued from
the island by Benjamin Lockwood one of
John Hammonds closest allies however
when Lockwood is betrayed by his
assistant
Eli Mills the surviving dinosaurs are
auctioned off on the black market in
true Jurassic world fashion the auction
goes badly and several of the almost
cartoonish villains and black-market
dealers end up getting eaten by the
prehistoric creatures during this
rampage several of the dinosaurs escaped
into the mainland of America and the
characters of the film are left living
in a true Jurassic world see what I did
there similar to the Planet of the Apes
series humans must now decide whether
they wish to coexist with the dinosaurs
or wage war on them this is obviously
where the sequels will head and in my
mind I can foresee the dinosaurs being
the victors in the end pal I mean it's
not like they pretty much been the
humans and eating them
every point during the previous movies
right whilst Bryce Dallas Howard
character only releases 18 species into
the wild and they are all female we've
seen in the prior films that this does
not matter and that life finds away and
because of this the animals are able to
reproduce we also see vials of DNA from
the different species in the hands of
Mills goons this suggests that there's a
definite possibility of further cloning
ball and Kingdom already touched on the
idea of weaponizing dinosaurs and while
this was only explored as a concept by
the prototype in the Raptor who's dead
by the end of the movie there's
certainly scope to take this further
however Colin Trevorrow has confirmed
that he is done with hybrids and that no
further sequels will feature them this
point is thematically hammered home by
the fact that the Raptor blue is the
cause of the Indo Raptors death and
therefore showcases that natural animals
always outperform those engineered and
allow we also see blue escaped into the
wild refusing to return to captivity and
suggesting that perhaps the focus of the
final Jurassic world film will instead
be centred on her arc as opposed to a
new monster
one of the biggest twists in the film is
the reveal at Lockwood's daughter /
granddaughter Maisie is in fact a clone
Lockwood's child was killed in a car
crash but he had the means and so opted
to use her DNA to create a new version
which he raised as his granddaughter
it's hinted at the fact that this caused
Lockwood and Hammonds friendship to fall
apart and could highlight a direction
that future sequels could discuss I
believe that down the line the question
of Hammonds hypocrisy will be raised and
there will perhaps be conflict over the
fact that he sees no wrong in cloning
life for monetary value but not to
replace deceased loved ones it's an
interesting theme and I really hope that
this is picked up in greater detail
in the movies post-credit scenes we see
the pterodactyls flying around the
eiffel tower replica in Las Vegas it's a
neat little gag that highlights the
duplication and commercialization of
originals that are then transformed into
commodities similar to how the dinosaurs
themselves were I chuckled at it but it
doesn't really do anything more than had
a cool shot and reconfirm that their
Jurassic world film will take place in
mainland America this closes out the
film and for better or worse confirms
that we will definitely be getting a
sequel so what did you think of Jurassic
world falling Kingdom how would you rank
it in the series from best to worst and
what would you like to see in any
potential sequels comment below and let
me know and if you'd like to see more of
my ending explain videos then please
subscribe to my channel I release videos
like this weekly and they're definitely
something on the channel that you love
recently I explained the ending of the
Netflix original film cargo as well as
what I think caused the virus in that
movie again thanks very much for taking
the time to watch this and I'll see you
next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]